[Music]
they say beauty is in the eye of the
beholder so what you might wonder does
this artist make of the pyramids in giza
she's called ada and she's a
british-built robot that uses cameras
and a robotic arm to create art
after being detained by egyptian customs
for 10 days ada made it to the site on
the edge of cairo in time for a unique
art show her contribution is this large
clay sculpture with three legs based on
the greek riddle of the sphinx and lying
sideways inside a metal and glass
sarcophagus
ada's hands had to be covered with
gloves to protect the electric wires
from the water and clay
we're astonished by the sorts of
technologies that are coming through on
the human side so either their
mechanical humanoid is actually
foreshadowing what can be done
biologically and so we're very concerned
about that and this sculpture really
keys into those aspects the wider art
show is called forever is now it's the
first of its kind at the giza plateau a
unesco world heritage site
it features pieces by creators from
around the world many referencing the
location in their works
ten artists have participated two
egyptians and eight foreigners as you
can see we have huge sculptures some of
them were made in egyptian factories it
was honestly a great experience it's
about
us coming together
and the time where
in a place where civilization
uh basically started and now it's a
rebirth because of covet we've been uh
separated for a year and a half and
humanity is starting to come together
again and it just goes to prove that
when we work together we can
achieve anything
so an international selection of artists
including a mechanical humanoid although
they do risk being upstaged by nature's
own display
nadine barber al jazeera